speaking of black men who need no
affirmative action kanye west baby i
haven't listened to the album yet but
he's got a new album coming out it's
called donda
and i i'm not maybe we'll do an analysis
of the album at some point he's got a
cool new gadget that he uses to to mix
the album that it's like this very
innovative gadget that coincidentally a
friend of mine built
so that's cool in and of itself but what
i want to focus on here is
he had a listening party for this last
night and the central set piece
was a chapel with a big cross
and the action on stage he actually had
marilyn manson there kind of
representing the devil
his marilyn manson is a probably the
most famous satanist in the country
it was representing spiritual warfare
and i just thought amid all the crazy
madness that's going on right now
there is a little glimmer of hope
there's always a little glimmer of hope
even as the world decays which is that
the most famous popular musician in the
world
is an outspoken christian
and some people are saying that kanye's
just pretending to be a christian just
to be weird just to be eccentric just to
keep people guessing
i mentioned i have at least one mutual
friend with kanye west others as well
what they tell me is he's 100 serious
he's 100 sincere and that is a that is a
wonderful thing we can't even admit all
this craziness we can't lose sight of
genuinely inspiring
encouraging moments speaking of which
though i can't leave on that high note
we will get to the mailbag in a second
but i have to note this
harvard harvard university just hired a
new chaplain you know chaplin is the
pastor this religious leader at a
university in the military wherever the
prison
the new chaplain at harvard is an
atheist
they just hire this guy greg epstein is
a 44 year old writer of good without god
he's the new chaplain
he's going to coordinate the religious
life
of harvard
he
who is an atheist and a lot of people
are saying this is insane you know the
conservatives are saying this is insane
the liberals are saying it's very clever
it's so subversive it's so clever i
think it's just common sense i think
it's totally ordinary because
everybody's got to serve somebody
the the absence of religion what people
think is the absence of religion is a
religion of itself you can't help but
make certain ethical metaphysical claims
about the world and the official
religion of harvard is atheism and the
official religion of our country right
now is atheism by the way and so it
stands to reason that the chaplain of
harvard and
chaplain of other influential
institutions in america would be an
atheist too
he's a lapsed jew but he's now
that's gone he's just an atheist
not surprising at all that's that's the
most popular religion in america
up up up don't hit that button don't hit
that next video button just wait one
second if you wouldn't mind leave me a
comment say hello say hi michael i'll
say hey there hey buddy what's going on
subscribe ring the bell like it head on
over apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play type in the michael knowles
show subscribe
leave a five star review is there
anything else i can ask you to do before
we go no i don't think so see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you